the problem in the 70s in my time is
that women were told we could do
anything and this comes even back to M
go mayor when she won her Nobel Prize
the newspaper here wrote San Diego
housewife wins a Nobel Prize and that's
because everybody had to say it's okay
that she's doing size because she's also
doing all of her women's jobs too well
this is not possible it's not possible
for us to do twice as much so you will
have around the world gender Equity when
we also let men look after the children
and the elderly I don't think women are
more caring than men I think that's just
as offensive saying that women aren't as
smart as men if everything was equal and
everybody took their share and everybody
could have an equal shot at it